réalité des aéroports du pays a bien
changé au cours des derniers mois les
aérogares sont maintenant vides tout
comme les avions
chez air canada l'achalandage a diminué
de 95 % depuis le début de la crise sur
258 appareils 225 sont cloués au sol à
compter du 7 juin jusqu'à 60% des 38
mais l'employé seront remerciés plus de
vingt mille personnes en grande partie
des agents de bord devront ranger leurs
uniformes pour une période indéterminée
une crise sanitaire sans précédent
il demande aux jo
de tout temps restait ses environs on
n'a pas de choix pour le rassurer nos
pour assurer tout le monde j'espère j'y
serais arrivé sain et sauf et tous les
gens monsieur madame tout le monde qui a
comme une perte d'emploi une diminution
de leur pouvoir d'achat où les parts et
parlent leur premier réflexe n'est pas
de sauter dans un avion de dallas en
voyage pour minimiser le nombre de
licenciements air canada demandera aux
agents de bord de réduire leurs heures
de prendre un congé pouvant aller
jusqu'à 2 ans ou de démissionner tout en
conservant des privilèges de voyage le
syndicat fait tout ce qu'il peut pour
protéger les emplois de ses 10000
membres à jean de bach et affirmé
finaliser la négociation des mesures de
mitigation et d'autres éléments avec
l'employeur nous savons que c'est un
grand défi pour les compagnies aériennes
ottawa a décidé de prolonger son
programme des subventions salariales
d'urgence pour les grandes entreprises
jusqu'au mois d'août nous allons
continuer de nous assurer que les gens
gardent ce lien avec leur employeur pour
qu'on puisse revenir rapidement une fois
cette crise terminée pour l'instant air
canada ne s'est pas engagé à utiliser
cette aide au delà du 6 juin
certains croient qu'il faudrait plus
qu'une aide d'urgence si on veut sauver
l'industrie
il va falloir monter des plans
spécifiques pour le secteur de
l'aviation dans ce tome est là on est
très très très lent pour supporter ce
secteur-là
selon l'association internationale du
transport aérien les vols internationaux
pourrait reprendre cet automne mais le
retour à la normale n'est pas prévu
avant 2023
il s'y marie michèle aux ondes radio
canada à montréal